[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right welcome back to the break room
this is our daily live show that keeps
you updated on all the nerdy news you
need to know right here from our very
own break room coming to you live from
the surface of the sun it's a thousand
degrees and it's only getting hotter if
you were here yesterday i complained
about the heat well
buckle up buckaroos because i'm gonna
keep complaining about it it's a hot day
but it's friday baby we're so happy to
be here having a hot show with all of
you coming up on the show today we pour
one out for our fan domies
mourn you till we join yet uh have namor
swimming powers been nerfed uh and and
see
well we'll find out
and will some old foes finally be
reunited i don't know plus as you saw on
the thumbnail we're discussing megan the
stallions in canon powers we know
they're there we know they exist uh but
before we get to all that i'm brandon
nice to meet you who gives a crap uh but
next to me we got coy jondrum
and little chris evans and a little
chris evans on wheel what's that
mysterious wheel you're asking you'll
find out soon enough but before we find
out i hate i hate this we're awesome
with jessica clement you guys if uh if
you know if you know what it's like to
have bras in the chat the wire just came
out of mine oh and it hurts in real time
that sad face in the chat for exposed
wires went out for
but next to jessica clemens keeping it
together as she always is we have our
birthday boy
it's erica
birthday
hey internet happy to be here we'd sing
the song but we can't afford to sing it
we don't have the rights
we don't have the rights but what we do
have the right to do is this little
mysterious thing behind me the wheel now
john john's not here today producer
john's not here today well we've got the
a crew back john's on the b crew but we
got the a crew back there uh and because
john's not here we're broke we're
breaking something out that we totally
wait for him for but we're not uh this
is our new redemption wheel we're gonna
give this a try today and see how it
goes uh and in honor of erica wu's
birthday we busted this bad boy out of
storage uh and every fifty dollars in
super chats we're gonna spin the wheel
and perform the redemption we land on
now what's on the wheel you might be
asking i'm not gonna read them all to
you but we've got
mysterious shots of strange colored
liquids you might have to take yeah we
got some oh please don't spill those
through the carpet i've served before
we've got mystery boxes we can hulk out
we can have to eat marshmallows we could
get covered in silly string i don't know
we've got all sorts of different things
i don't want to know what's on the wheel
so please don't do any super chats uh no
you can join me erica which is brilliant
every time we hit 50. every time we hit
50. we've already got a super chat
coming in from you capri test saying
hello nerd babies big head gang bechdel
[ __ ] none of those people here today
peaches and cream keep it in gucci to
moochie i'm sorry that neither mt or
tommy are on the show for you i could be
both of them if you want yeah well we
could be all of them combined together i
could be uh mc stan and why not yeah
also i never know i love that the the
wheel has been broken out for my
birthday which i appreciate yeah and
it's got my favorite hollywood chris on
it so that's always the best question
no
how dare you no that man is a menace he
must be stopped at all costs that's why
he's forced to stay uh in las vegas
las vegas
where all criminals are forced to be uh
but before we talk more about chris
angel let's talk about these headlines
[Music]
already sweating so much i thought yeah
keep the camera on those two for a
minute
[Applause]
you should never poke the bear all right
this is our first headline today and
it's it's quite something uh excellent
fully worked for yourself
dc fandom 2022 is no more it's been
killed wait oh yeah uh it's done baby uh
warner brothers discovery on their has
decided to cancel their global virtual
fan event uh that showcases upcoming
projects now you may remember they
started this back in 2020 it's pretty
new it was pretty fresh thing but they
did this during the pandemic it was
pretty successful so he did it again in
2021 also successful i run a great time
i love the last year yeah tuning in from
home seeing trailers seeing footage uh
but with all the project cancellations
and release delays on the jacket for
warner brothers it seems uh it's time
for the event to come to an end maybe
it'll be back someday i don't know but
that's sad
it's it's i liked it it was a really
special thing to feel like you could be
at home and have a con and that was a
hard balance because everyone tried to
do that i feel like fandom was the most
successful but i would like it maybe
it'll come back stronger than ever wow
and i definitely can't do it this year
no that's the whole problem is like
every question every prod would just be
about like let's see
just jason my mom would be in like two
minutes in 15 months you guys are gonna
see the movie that's been done for a
year i guess like walking
oh my god it's all of them it's black
adam just keeps coming out yeah he has
come out to how many events now that's
awesome
oh yeah yeah but we all thought after
comic-con and the kind of small dc
presence they're like well they're by
saving it for their their homegrown
event but i guess not i guess not yeah
uh in some positive warner brothers news
brendan gleeson has joined the cast of
joker too oh i didn't know that i
disclosed roles oh that's one of my
favorite actors in the world that's
exciting i mean penguin could be penguin
to a big penguin i think it will be
frank wine
penguin penguin i would like two irish
penguins please yeah yeah college
penguin he looks like him looks like a
penguin a little bit not like there's
other big boys on the the uh
artillery of batman the rogue gallery i
see him as a mr pig a mr pig oh the guy
that does like he wants to master like
he's kind of like a the high
evolutionary where he's like trying to
make the perfect thing and he does all
sorts of like grotesque surgeries and
stuff i hope he doesn't i hope he
doesn't
i think that's one zero part of that i
don't i don't know this for a reason i
don't like this i like this yeah i was
living a great life before i knew about
this thing pyg google
next headline uh multiverse of madness
writer michael waldron gave some more
insight into the origin of black bolt's
death scene from multiverse of madness
when they were writing the script uh
waldron said that they realized quote
the movie needs to get drunk which i
love this quote okay uh we wanted the
first death to feel really horrific
like kind of a listen don't [ __ ] with
wanda kind of situation and i guess it
was actually sam raimi as they were kind
of pitching ideas on how to kill black
ball and talking about his powers sam
rapey he uttered the phrase what mouth
and then like kind of laid out what
would happen if this guy who with the
destructive voice didn't have a mouth uh
and it was grotesque and then loved it
so good on you sam raimi it was actually
a very interesting interview they talked
about a lot of things in it he also
talked about how like sam raimi at first
didn't want to do like zombie strange
because he was like i don't want to just
do a zombie strange to just do it
because i'm sam raimi and it's like
people doing poor guy yeah but they like
worked it out and he he liked michael
waldron's reasonings and it was like sam
raimi who came up with the idea with
like well if you're doing all this why
not have these like demons who are
trying to get him and sam right now that
cloak was right came up with the cloak
and stuff so very cool uh it's always
fun to hear about the creative process
for these movies uh and i loved it loved
it next headline when speaking with the
spanish language outlet and i think this
is the name of it think like a new man
life and style i was very confused by
the name like a grammar there was
confusing yeah yeah well it was like
it said life and style and big text and
a little text that said think like a new
man i don't know if it's some weird men
go their own way situation i don't know
but tanakh
he had an interview with them and he
revealed that he doesn't or didn't know
how to swim i don't know if he knows now
i hope he does
but when he was cast as neymar
he said quote oh they also asked me if i
could swim like on the way out and his
response was uh i have never drowned
i love that answer you're just kind of
like oh i've never drowned like left the
room quickly and then kind of told his
managers like hey i don't know how to
swim anyone that's ever done an audition
knows your special skills include
whatever they're asking you like i can
do archery i am an excellent equestrian
he got cast he's like i'm a learner yeah
if you're gonna make that marvel bag
you'll be like i can hire someone to
hire some trainers
that's amazing i know swordplay i can be
yeah in blade sure yeah
master swordsman
i love actors i did that chloe grace
moretz did it for the um oh my god uh
martial
no it's a master's movie where i think
it's marcus lazy but uh he was like i
want a young british girl and so she's
like i'm very british
and then it was on passing it out where
he's like good job and she said thanks
and went oh girl
she got the rule oh i love that so much
uh i also liked in this interview
tonight said that this this movie is
quote one of the most rebellious in
marvel history
you know uh he and he was kind of
bringing up how like neymar is
anti-capitalist anti-colonialism so like
you might get into some very interesting
concepts in this movie i don't know uh
they're gonna flood the world i don't i
don't know we'll see uh on to our next
headline peyton reed the director of
ant-man los quantomania has been
praising jonathan major's work uh on the
film and he said quote it's become a
cliche over the decades to compare
somebody to a young marlon brando but
jonathan has that uh peyton reed also
said he he has just the energy and
presence that our movie is definitely
benefiting from that uh i guess saying
you know from what he saw on loki to
what he's doing now it's like great
stuff there was also like a funny quote
that came out of this article we were
talking about this
uh he he was saying like the marvel
stuff is like kind of like clown work
which is very funny because uh the other
actor said that yesterday about being in
aquaman two oh yeah yeah like marvel
work is clown work and everyone was
taking it like the wrong way it works
hard man works such a beautiful
presentation yeah he describes it as
like the clown is the one that like
disrupts things and brings like new
concepts in and it's a lot of work they
both went to yale you have to go to
clown school at yale if you're doing the
acting program so like i think people
like undermine clowns clowning is like
one of the hardest professions well i
think clown has become a popular meme
you know like putting on the clown
makeup and becoming the clown and also
being terrified by clowns running again
that was a whole wave the world's true
the word
is very loaded you know yeah uh we did
we've been running some polls uh do you
think brendan gleason will play an
existing dc character or someone new 56
saying existing dc character um
yeah i don't think they would make up a
new character i don't know i mean joker
if there's ever one it would be jokingly
joker it would be joker uh do you think
black bolt's death was the most gruesome
mcu death we've seen 72 saying yes what
about frank frank from ant-man shrunk
down to a goo and flush down the toilet
disgusting act a disgusting act yeah uh
also said in those super giants i i know
i said don't do it but please do it
jessica worked so hard on the wheel it's
erica roose's birthday it's erica who's
his birthday
i i made sure sam our office coordinator
got everything for us to break into we
have stuff that we could be consuming
for you guys it could be incredible
stuff it could be awful stuff also will
will never have tommy back on the show
unless you make us spin the wheel unless
you make us miss or you made koi eat
another jalapeno man that was rough that
was so nice i don't think we have any
jalapenos broke my juice cleanse with
pain and fire i can't wait
to get one next headline tim roth had a
slew of interviews come out uh where
he's been kind of discussing his work on
she-hulk first he's been praising
marvel's comedic approach on the show he
said quote i think what tatiana from
what i saw on set and what she's done is
quite remarkable and what i know of her
journey through the show i think will
surprise and delight the audience i like
to be nice
he also mentioned how like they gave him
like this big binder about like what
she-hulk is all about uh and it reminded
me of just the fact they had a binder on
the show that the whole cat about being
in the hallway that's actually the show
yeah yeah i respect that uh he also tim
ross said when asked if abomination was
still a villain he said quote i can't
answer that for you classic work
he's been kept in maximum security
solitary confinement for a very long
time what does that do to someone where
does that lead him and who is this guy
now should we have a leap of faith in
him or not there's more to come you'll
see i know it's coming i hope we get
away with it i can only say that
i hope we get away with it i think how
is tim roth better at answering this
than anyone else from the marvel
cinematics he's had a lot of time off
but i feel like from the marvel universe
in the mirror every day he thinks about
it he was like oh we have 50. oh hey
why don't jeremiah's birthday boy right
spin it hard
woo
20 minutes
20 minutes later all right he hasn't
really greased the wheels it's really
spinny hulk out oh god oh oh
i wanted you to do a new one you want to
hook out on your birthday
oh what do i [ __ ] out give me give me a
thing what do i hulk out about you want
to hulk out about your birthday how do
you feel sure yeah about birthdays
birthdays in general okay about that
email you got from starbucks and you
have to get it today five bucks
one day a year only one day a year all
right here we go
eric hulk out about birthday because
eric was born
somehow a number of years ago today
hollywood secrets say never reveal true
age
only look baby face and let people
assume
her birthdays are great eric likes sugar
so eric liked birthday cake and candy
and anything else anyone wants to slide
eric's way like a sweet sweet margarita
you're over 21.
oh
yes
so he wants to do liquor commercials you
gotta yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah
what's your plans tonight
plans tonight are to go party on a
friday and at a friday themed costume
party
somewhere in los angeles
with good friends who want to come and
also dress up as characters from the 90s
early 2000s black stoner comedy
franchise
eric smash and smoke probably
[Applause]
i'm proud of you good job good job
thank you what a hulk out
thank you lion of demise and thank you
this is me and thank you you complete
this yeah yeah thank you thank you all
uh and our redemption will currently
sitting at 69.
immediately
[Laughter]
um speaking of the treatment of
abomination uh it came out in another
interview from uh tim roth that kevin
feige originally wanted to sink
abomination to the bottom of the ocean
uh tim ross said quote i remember
talking to kevin on set and this was on
the set of the incredible hulk with
stanley as well r.i.p uh and he said the
idea was that they locked him up in a
steel vault and sank it to the bottom of
the ocean and left it there so that when
you found it at the beginning of
whatever film that might have been
that's where you found him and he had
time to think about what he wanted to do
and where he wanted to go it's like kind
of getting a similar arc yeah yeah
that you open up in like a hundred years
yeah you've been him time capsule like
what that happened to davey jones and
the pirates of the caribbean that's why
they took it away they were locked into
them uh our boy will turner get like
sent to the bottom of the ocean or
something i forget and then there's been
a while uh a charlize theron movie where
they were like oh yeah invincible like
yeah they lived throughout time yeah i
forget the name oh that netflix movie
right yeah i always like that when they
do this to villains who like can't die
like they jump in true blood right where
they put up in concrete and just bury
him in the ground
he's like still alive but just waiting
just waiting interview at the vampire
lestat trapped in that casket bricked up
yeah yeah yeah come on classic
uh some meal as i say samil says and
that's how he got the fish fish
oh how should we punish this guy
well we do know at agents of shield at
one point they mentioned like oh
abominations on ice in the vault and
like alaska or antarctica or something
like that but it was like interesting
kevin's like yeah we'll just put them in
the ocean until we need them uh that's
great uh and finally in the tim roth
section of our news stories today uh
he's been teasing a scene with ho was
she with sorry with uh she-hulk and
bruce and abomination altogether he had
this other quote that was kind of
talking about like how good mark and
tatiana are on the show but he was
saying quote i was a couple
i was a couple days in and they were
deep into shooting and i had to do a
scene with mark ruffalo and tatiana
mosley so does that mean do you think uh
him saying this do you think this is a
scene that was going to be cut or do you
think hope might actually come back in
this show
it seemed like they were taking it out
yeah this was his guard like he's gone
yeah she was like
but i don't believe that i don't yeah
there's been a lot of interviews where
i'm like just kidding i got a lot of
questions and we're also friends now so
jessica gao oh hello yes jessica pick up
simulator come by the studio yeah come
hang out whole marvel family yeah and
bring the whole mark
um but i i don't i don't know i'm really
50 50 on that because i do think he's
like gone for good because they do want
to make sure it's her show yeah she's
even like like it's just her show right
so maybe
but then at the very very end yeah i can
see some like someone comes looking for
him maybe
i just feel like it would so undermine
the world war hulk stuff that we all
feel but then marvel's been doing a lot
of like you think it's this
yeah so that's very popular always like
come back to earth and be like gotta go
again
yeah just pick it up just hit him in
space pop it around forgot to take my
laptop last time like i know mephisto is
a dirty woman all these parts but not
your birthday but you keep just dropping
the camera here come on
around here
oh my god i ruined it
[Music]
yeah just an example of like we think it
might be one thing and then disney's
like psych you know yeah yeah here we go
i like how you did psych like you're
cracking a neck
i think we i think we broke it again
invite chrissy to the break room
me and chris are going out to dinner
tomorrow wow
actually everyone's invited to dinner as
long as we all split the seafood boil
it's very expensive i was told uh i'm up
next according to the uh
oh yeah
much like the hulk out okay okay
he's going i like how he's going full
price of right yeah he's going full
price or right i love the joints no
whammy no way no we're not doing it
what gets me marshmallows
oh my gosh
it's causing too much energy
oh thank god oh
my gosh what gets me marshmallows oh you
want you want to do chubby bunny chubby
bunny me let's get after it i've been
eyeballing that marshmallows
that's the only rule you cannot i'll
sign whatever nda and waiver that is
necessary for this bunny that is
please do not choke yourself
recommend the comic that you want to
recommend to our audience okay
chubby bunny hulk or anything any any
comic any car okay
i think the most accessible comic book
for anyone is ultimate spider-man
sometimes
because i find it's good for basically a
modern audience to understand the 60
sensibilities you said the original
spider-man ultimate ultimate
uh-huh
[Laughter]
wrestling but he'll never beat me on
chocolate
to the bathroom bunny a there's a trash
can just by the water fountain over
there oh you want to eat that one
all right
good job boys
thank you for the birthday wishes he's
trying so hard you almost killed koi
he might he might still die who knows we
can't we can't promise that but while
koi uh tries his best not to choke to
death we want to remind you to head out
over here
he's too much of anything as good as it
is let the boy live please look at he
got quiet and stood there
be sure to head on over to
newrockstarsmerch.com where you can
check out our two latest obsession
shirts that we have right now both of
these limited edition shirts won't last
long the one on your right there is lady
justice inspired by the she-hulk series
of course and the one on your left is
ashen ruin inspired by house of the
dragon and which is currently on hbo max
drop our banners we got vanish you might
see uh you can check out talking dragons
on uh uh on mondays it'll be tuesday
this week but on mondays after house of
the dragon or jessica and i kind of
recap the show or check out inside
marvel where jessica and mtn eric break
down or react to the most recent
episodes of she-hulk both of these
latest obsession shirts if you buy them
you unlock the opportunity to get a
custom shout out that'll appear on these
after shows or might even be read live
on the air who knows you never know just
check them out check out all of our
awesome march options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com you won't be
disappointed check it out yay you guys
uh we are so close to getting to our
another 50 well we'll spin the wheel me
or brandon probably uh we'll spin the
wheel and if it's your choice i'm gonna
make koi do it again
i'm going for seven
both of you are sadistic and i love this
so this is hard how did you do seven
dozen marshmallows
oh yeah i don't have the i don't have
the like
squirrel element and i could have done
more but brandon told me to stop because
i'm so impressed i just don't know what
happened to brandon's channel free warns
me about chubby bunny she wanted stuff
and i i never wanted me
she didn't warn us about dr oz
unfortunately but she didn't
yeah she can't save us from everything
okay oprah can do so much so you guys
our thumbnail today is what super powers
does megan the stallion have and this is
for good fun because today's friday and
we like to have fun and it's also eric's
birthday and eric loves making this town
sure do you do for multiple reasons so
we're gonna figure out what in the mcu
could megan the stallion be close to i
love celebrities that become canon in
the mcu and i think this one
specifically is like don't let her go
yeah like bring it up bring up
eventually later bring up ten years from
now be like hey oh megan the stallion
actually had the power to twerk an
earthquake into like the atlantic so
this is where we're gonna start we're
gonna start with people that are kind of
close to megan the stallion um who we
think who we think well what and your
reasoning for that she has powers is
because she's signed with jennifer
walters and she has to be a superhero
attorney this is the superhero this is
the superhero law division do you want
to stand up so people can see the people
yeah we can stand up because if you guys
don't agree with mine you don't have to
stand up it's your birthday um if you if
you i'm a king today
if you guys uh agree or disagree you too
you guys you have right there
yeah yeah you can write the names here i
got i got an idea i think i know who she
is who okay so i'm going to go okay i'm
not going to look with an x-men oh you
want to just
do tons i i have a couple x-men in my in
my little repertoire
i thought it said booty
the booty's implied no booty's in black
boom boom wait can i say this
like take the cap
so boom boom has the power she's like
jubilee but like in custom blast you
just kind of caught it
so like i mean what better power that
would cause the earthquake like i mean i
feel like boom boom well see so my first
experience is dazzler because we know
that dazzler um oh my gosh she was
possible as a performer but it's the
lights that kind of gave off during the
show and i just think keeping a
performer with a performer like magic is
something subtle that can be applied
later on yeah yeah you guys agree or
disagree oh there's more coming through
yeah we can agree we'll put her up on
the board yeah oh she's not glued oh we
have my magnets dude
how do they work this is mesmerized
and nikoi do you want to explain what
mesmero is uh mesmero uh is very similar
to the guy with the hat where his like
basically does his hypnosis but he
doesn't need the hat even though he
wears a silly hat he he's like a a not a
poor man a rich man's mysterio like his
powers actually come from him as opposed
to like magic and he has a great cape
isn't he a hypnotist yeah that's
something he doesn't know he doesn't
need the hat so sorry he's a hypnotist
that doesn't need the hat and he also
doesn't either
s
that's the name of the hypnotist that
was in this old spider-man comics with
the hat the the circuit the big
the circus guy i remember him
he like always like kidnapped people
during circuses like the big hat
if you know this it's like a 1963 stan
lee steve trying dicker the thing i'm
talking about i only know it because i
had to look into a lot of hypnotists for
a lot of reasons recently and so i was
like i think i know it but he's like
that guy but without the hat i put him
up here because i think if we're trying
to she's mesmo she's she's hypnotizing
we get her we're obsessed with her we're
drawn to her she can do whatever she
wants right go ahead and look it up
someone that also can do whatever they
want what if she is just a god
chrissy in the chat please come get at
me so
k is it possible
is it possible you guys for a god for a
normal human to be worshipped so much
that they're turned to a god
so that's what i'm saying is megan the
stallion has such a high following and
then in the mc like i know they did this
in danny phantom there was a the
character that goes that could play
music and just basically entrance and
trance so i'm like what if she is just a
mini god kind of like dionysus that she
is like a lord of partying hmm
i like that ring master is the dude's
name i remember one master
i was so close oh people weren't putting
thank you chat you guys are great master
thank you chat
also you guys calling her a booty god oh
chrissy breaking up the tulpas i'm here
for the topaz santa claus is the tulpa i
believe it let's go
wait what do you mean tulpa is if you
believe in if enough people believe in a
thing it becomes real yes yes yes thank
you
like the jersey devil
oh so that so
i mean we are believing it well some
cryptoids could be tulpas it goes back
and forth so it's kind of a reverse
mandela effect yeah it's like enough
people believe in it it causes it to
become like cryptocurrency
if enough people believe in this thing
it's money so now that and even if we're
getting closer to secret wars i don't
know if she'll play this big of a part
but volcano
um i think not only is she
she built just like a girl she built
like my girl she's built like my girl
but what if dr doom is using also megan
the stallion
doctor doom after secret wars is like
do you want power do you want some power
[Music]
you know dr doom definitely is like oh
yeah thicker
i just wanted to be the frankenstein but
but going
also going off
which everyone's saying and i know some
of you guys are irritated by it but we
can't keep thinking it won't happen get
him she's a scroll oh okay oh okay she's
a scroll you but she was already uh a
shape-shifting out see well she wasn't
the shape-shifting enough roona was the
shape shift you know that's true i i
would say it seems like an intentional
mislead by the way why would they not
use a scroll right
which makes me think there is a scroll
in the show because we don't want to be
alerted to the reminded of the scrolls
yeah until this time because we haven't
seen him once uh
one division right yeah but like we're
not thinking of them now sorry uh ego i
see you in the chat where's the thick
meter we ain't got one today
it's time
it was too high i think we got two spins
let me go spin really quick in the
middle i do want to come back oh wow
we'll come back yeah rosario sending in
a super chat saying can we give a raise
to whoever made that whiteboard that
scene was hilarious that's sam give her
a raise yeah kudos to sam we love an
artist it's it's heavily weighted on
that spin yeah i need to get rid of the
spin again
i feel way better about my double spin
again i know please don't give me a
triple please don't give me trouble oh
mystery shot
do you know what they are
oh good that's what you get yes that's
what happens jess this is i'll bring it
to you yeah it's your birthday don't
that's gotta be me
i have the same questions i assume one's
milk definitely i'm not giving away
berry pizza
i'm gonna give you this one that has
layers to it
all these shot glasses are from golden
girls and this one is sophia
oh it's sharp it's like onion shark oh
is it oh
it smells like radishes taste
oh was it one of those like ginger shots
it it tastes like a healthy shot and
that's why i was buying a wellness shop
that's probably why i don't like it
that's good for you it's gonna be a long
weekend thank you jeff good preps you're
getting involved yeah right
are you doing too
oh you get to hook out jess you don't
want
one i want to do it i want you got a
variety
we have so many no
the irony
the rules of the wheel are falling out
the window
all right
what do you want to do i oh no wanna
catify oh she wants and i know what you
guys are wondering what is catify um
i want to cater for koi oh you're gonna
fight somebody else
let's do it bring it on i consent this
is for you i can send to my catification
welcome this is gonna be quick walk away
oh i'm like getting painted it's just a
little bit okay
we did put up a tweet earlier today we
asked uh you know what powers do you
think megan v stallion might have got
some great answers uh
uh from at blacklion561
she got the power to make even the
strongest mcu characters twerk to her
music mm-hmm which i like that she loves
i like that too i like almost like a
jiggly puff like you can make her do she
has like hypnosis powers to her song she
also has another incredible power where
she makes
heroes and anti-heroes other universes
want to be her pet oh
that's like that and an incredible power
uh
at colonial underscore beef saying she
has the power of extreme hydration
first of all
i may only have a six marshmallow mouth
but my hands are way too big for these
gloves you gotta keep it all on today of
course you're really being punished
today i just saw some sort of friday
were you excited for the marshmallows
that's true i did that that made a try
uh
at southern sam said the thunderclap
winky face
that's a good one to clap them cheeks
you know what i mean uh i think it'll be
funny if she's twerking and it causes
ripples there is a great there's a great
edit out there if you look around oh
yeah the of uh megan the stallion and uh
uh
doing their twerking and then they they
there's a different one they subbed in
uh the hulk being like knocked back by
the sound respect that editor of the
rumbling uh
at so yeah i'm asian that was their name
i didn't give them a name
so yeah i'm asian saying uh judging by
her dance move indestructible acls
said it's in her name she can
shape-shift but only into a human she's
actually a stallion which there were a
lot of shape-shifting answers but i do
have the idea that she's a horse that
can turn into a human that's her only
power wait wait wait wait wait she's
literally making the stallion and she
became a few people oh like
wait wait no that one might be the best
who did that one that was from at the
freaking prize
a stallion that turns into a horse
superhero that's that's hannah
a horse that's powered and turns into a
human loving uh wouldn't it be fun
wouldn't it be great tommy in the chat
did you have any other heroes
stop you guys
wait hold on
what did grumpy cat's face it was like
yeah yeah
thank you riley tommy tommy out here
furthering the conspiracy that this show
is taped it's not taped it's live it's
live all the time do you have any other
heroes or powers you think do you guys i
love the ones from twitter more than
mine
that one's so funny a horse that turns
into us
like
a super person i mean she turned out to
be a god that could be fun realistically
which i hate to be this person but you
guys know i have to because i do the
breakdowns realistically i think she's a
client to jennifer walters because she
was being tainted by roona so she's like
i need a client i need a lawyer that can
constantly be like hey we have another
shape-shifter that's appearing to be
yeah yeah so it's like she just needs
that and i think this is the greatest
client to grab because in the comics
they were like we only wanted you so you
could bring in like super popular super
famous people and she's bringing in
megan the stallion yeah true that's not
going to get the top that's
her first client oh well a second now
because right
second time
but the first one she picked her first
acquisition yes there i am pretty huge
we did ask the chat and it seems like of
the super powers we listed what makes
the most sense for megan d stallion uh
turning and turning sound into light was
like the top answer that kind of
dinosaurs powers there synesthesia
yes some sort of like manipulation of
sound and light that would be very
fascinating i like that idea well i like
the idea of her being basically like
storm so when she claps some cheeks
lightning comes
and that's her power static like each
other yeah
literally like the rubbing of the
fabrics yeah yes fabrics yeah i'm so
lucky at your bathroom
your bathroom it's my bastard
it's your birthday we we are happy that
it's eric it was his birthday uh we love
it more even more than earth day and we
really love the earth here and we want
to take care of the earth but what if i
told you that there was a credit card
that can tackle your negative impact on
climate uh just by using it once a day
there is uh it's the aspiration zero
credit card i really went in for that
and it didn't matter it is
you're enthused
aspiration zero is the first credit card
that fights climate change by planting
trees with every swipe you you plant two
trees with every purchase you make which
soaks up about the same amount of carbon
dioxide from the air as the average
american puts out every day and i'm out
there huffing and puffing as i walk down
the street putting out so much co2 but
two trees taking it off the board baby
and along with that you get unlimited
one percent cash back on all of your
monthly purchases when you hit carbon
zero for the month wouldn't that be
lovely to do aspiration has already
planted 75
million trees 75 million trees that's
one tree for every hater of she-hulk out
there you're out there playing them
trees okay make your dollars make a
difference apply for the aspiration zero
credit card today and earn a 300 welcome
bonus after spending three thousand
dollars in the first 90 days you can
apply right now at aspiration.com
break room to go carbon neutral
effortlessly and earn a 300 bonus take
it from me and the cat okay go to
aspiration.com
break room the aspiration zero
mastercard is issued by beneficial state
bank pursuant to licensed by mastercard
international incorporated good credit
is required terms and conditions do
uh
tommy in the chat saying that he'd love
to have corey on his lap
tommy notoriously hates all cats but i
think we've just turned him around on it
30 more dollars until we spin that wheel
again we still have two boxes we have it
open we have uh sculpt me we haven't
baby boy okay is this is this me
yeah
yeah
oh oh
my goodness it's pretty oh that cat's
pretty sexy he's not gonna lie my cat is
riley you had one job and it's to keep
the talent on camp
keep the talent on camera it's a very
talented puppy right there look at all
that that dog doesn't work for scale
okay
out of here you guys is the best best
time best segment i'm so glad to be
doing this while tommy's in the chat
it's you are a cat you are like oh my
god it's mandatory fun
i can't tell the graphics played dude
okay play one more time for me yeah
it says in the prompter play my graphic
times three so one more time please oh
did tommy get in the crowd bless up baby
for today's mandatory fun we can't get
enough of the wrecking crew i think a
lot of people online can't get enough of
the wrecking crew they're adorable
they're so dumb also i want to see a
full construction site in amsterdam
because it must be gorgeous well it's
probably newer
okay so when when they were fighting did
you get the sense of their like it
wasn't like choreography for fighting is
choreographer for dancing
those guys are definitely dancers yeah
it felt like i was at the the rave tent
at coachella or something like oh yeah
it was a little intense they were giving
uh they were absolutely giving just
dancers
they all got served and took it to the
streets
for sure took the streets go ahead girl
so we made our own goon squad you guys
uh everyone deserves a team of goon
squads just as stupid you gotta have
those low-level people the tracksuit
mafia and the wrecking crew the people
you just take out but they have a cute
theme going right so yeah and so our
teams they can be people from the mc if
you want it could be people from the dc
you it could be anyone mine is not do
you want you guys want to hear my videos
yeah
so my team okay if i was in the marvel
cinematic universe and i got a team of
goons if i was rich enough to hire them
i'd be like okay ladies we're all the
same bodies we're all think girls yeah
we're all thick girls it's all volcano i
think going women all women is is tough
because like if you're going up against
a guy for a second he's going to be like
i can't be caught on the news fighting
these women and i'm going to be like
i don't know
so it would be a team of women right and
we're kind of dressed like cheerleaders
kind of like cheerleaders but we all
have different colors i know what you're
thinking jessica are you guys gonna be
like the fanta girls yeah no
we're gonna be the sprites and we're all
we're all different ghosts that's right
and it's and it's funny because i'm
really paid by sprite
no are you gonna get sued by well the
thing is oh let them try i'm going to
beat their ass and then i'm going to
keep drinking their sprite i'm the
leader so i drink the mcdonald's sprite
the heart oh man that is some sprite the
biggest kicks
of the songs powers then yes are you
fueled by sprite yes okay oh we have to
drink this product
so
like a cat is your is your like pet
little penny you know because you're
just a can
oh oh oh
yeah
sure we can do that
since they were nickelodeons and you
could crank it yourself and you saw
edison electrocute an elephant who knows
where the days of cinema
our powers would be taking the cans and
like crushing them in the people's
mouths oh i would be like water ordering
them you could like pick up a like 12
pack and just
i don't know if that works or it's just
coke but i think faces off before it
drowns them oh my gosh up your nose
i'm sorry are we playing villains are we
playing
hey you're right you're right you're
villains you're going very vulnerable
next who's the other team
i got one
i uh
no i'm gonna i'm gonna go uh my hometown
i'm gonna i got a team they're called
the uh the [ __ ] townies and uh the
towns these townies are right in wrongs
and wrong and rights on every street
corner they live with their moths but uh
the moms are nice ladies they let them
stay up as late as they want uh they're
known to wear a nice velour tracksuit uh
they definitely know girls that go to
heaven uh they don't go to habit but
they know girls to go to heaven and uh
basically the problem is these guys just
want to get across the merrimack but
nobody drives a car like who has a car
uh so they stay with the maz and uh
basically this was just for jess
and they're and the wicked
the wicked resourceful kid wicked
resourceful
and every every week they gotta hit up
you know the the green monster that's
where they get the powers from is at
fenway you know all the energy of the
crowds they get to marinade in that and
that gives them their boston powers
yeah yeah i have a question
uh do they
uh
wear underwear because isn't it like a
common thing that people in boston don't
wear underwear only when it's 106. okay
is that a comment yes yesterday remember
koi brought it up he said in boston they
don't wear underwear they get tired
and sometimes it gets hot you guys and
now you understand why i make fun of
bostonians
that's one of
who's the leader
uh sean o'malley he's uh
who's the most boston comic book
character is there anything
space boston is canon thanks to bill
burr
disney has accepted space boston is that
space british they got space i feel like
banshee's the closest there aren't a lot
of like irish superheroes from or like
i'm from boston yeah like boston's new
ireland so like i feel like banshee by
by the distributive property of new
ireland banshee is our biggest enemy
because he's from the old country irish
he yeah but he said he's new york irish
and that's a different that's amazing
here it's a different culture
yeah
no no like chicago irish is like closer
to new york irish but like boston irish
is people that have been like five
generations at ireland like they're
they're like a very that's why banshee's
their guy that's true
uh can i see
[Music]
you guys are going all you straight to
horny jail straight to horny them
fingers is horny
yeah don't show it off don't show it off
who wants to go next
keep them tamed in the chat they'll be
taken okay it's his birthday
it's gonna be wet and sweaty
uh my group of villains is called the
viking vikings oh that's a good one and
they are very mobile they don't need a
car uh
they're very mobile they've all got
viking helmets and big fur so they're
big burly they may or may not be
inspired by the you know the asgardians
in new asgard but they run around
running amok causing havoc swinging
clubs picking up people's dogs and just
carrying them off in the night they
pillage they don't do that r word but
they pillaged nice uh so they're
villainous to a point
progress i respect that yeah yeah
they're modern vikings
yeah they're not trying to get cancelled
i appreciate that yeah yeah viking
vikings they've grown that's beautiful
as a culture do they okay when you say
biking vikings are they on
they're literally on bicycles
they're not bikers they're not like the
hell's angels they're trying to like
they're impacting them
they're very eco-friendly they use the
credit they use the credit card yeah for
sure
but they scam on the credit card
well they do they still club
[Music]
uh viking
by
viking vikings on a t-shirt i would
absolutely wear that i would absolutely
hire you i bet there's a bike crew out
there called the viking vikings yeah
they're all the very old men with the
long beards adorable they get caught in
the spokes
i wrote down mine don't worry don't
worry chad also you guys we're so close
to breaking that 50 for brandon i want
brandon she wants to spend this wheel
and i get right there
i want someone
don't worry don't worry chet this is a
real bonus i just love how like thursday
the friday
tommy i mean everybody it's just
horses
let's see some bony horses in the chat
my my low-level uh uh crew is gonna be
this is the spud squad also known as the
potato posse very similar to my squad
we're working out the names okay these
are all potato-based henchmen i know i
got four guys up front okay okay we got
tots okay he shoots like high-speed
tater tots out those little bullets
they're frozen so they hurt they come
out really super fast we got masher okay
he's big he's strong uh and he's able to
shift his body into like any kind of
shape kind of like clay face cool he's
like made of mashed potatoes i like a
guy he's masher uh we got french fry all
right he's french don't forget we we
and he shoots boiling hot grease at his
opponents and judgmental stuff yeah yeah
he's frying i like him
french fry and finally we got baked
potato okay he's a big dude he's he's
invulnerable to heat you can't you can't
get too high that's not bad for me never
mind right now
coming for you yeah
scared it out i think our crews fight i
think our crews fight
spin now i don't want to stay in that
wheel i don't don't hit spin again
again
but again lose your chair for 10 minutes
that's not fun you don't get 10 minutes
we'll take one for the road
which one left to right left to right
i'd say
there's not even a cupcake
that we actually have because we do have
like a couple of times um
did we already answer the poll do you
think abomination will be fully
rehabilitated
oh we did not the chat said no
i i i agree hell no um oh we're still
doing the pulls also to see you should
be doing this because i'm like where did
we leave off i think there's a question
up ahead yeah rosario l asked can we oh
we did that one sorry
um
um we also got out yooka said koi's guns
are destroying marriages
no no that she's filled it with a case
or maybe the fish in the background yeah
i'm going on vacation for two weeks
gonna miss you guys
have a good vacation on vacation next
week mike said that his wife said
nikki's outfits don't fit the timeline
take that nikki well she's in 2025 so
who knows she is she's like she's a
witch she's dressed up like she's from
the 70s or 80s she's head of fashion oh
yeah
fashion is cyclical you know maybe it
was hot and then it came back and style
you know who knows um
happy fridays uh
lots of happy birthdays in the super
chats uh i think you dressed me for
sending a super chat yeah it's unusual
massive they love the trash bags
[Laughter]
settle down
settle down to be fair we started
talking about meghan and she didn't get
cakes at the time at the time they just
they just took it and they're just there
just enticing cakes and thunder collapse
types of 29 cents on a super chat saying
when koi couldn't speak anymore during
stuff stuffy bunny which is a difference
all i could think of was what mouth it's
true
you almost had can we do one more spin
can i do one more time yeah i guess if
you want to do another
i just like this spinning wheel also
someone in the chat i think was a little
bit ways up in the super chat asked if i
was sterling k brown yeah
he is this is this is us
especially
i'll ask my daddy to see if he wants me
to tone it down oh god
[Music]
is in the front right here okay oh is
this clay you have 60 seconds to sculpt
one of us oh and we get to guess what
that sculpt which is
okay and while you're sculpting why
don't we because we haven't done it and
we're right behind we we don't have a
clip of the week for you but we do have
a clip of the month hey
[Applause]
the end of the session hey you know what
maybe it's not an eiffel tower but not
for power you know wow
you know the caboose might be empty
right now baby but you're gonna fill it
up all right
maybe
maybe maybe you got a suckling pig that
you need to spit roast okay
hey listen to me
you may see them as cowboys riding up on
the train to rob them you know what i
see new partners interesting people to
get to know throw some keys in a
fishbowl this weekend
take your wife out on a date wink at a
couple flash a pineapple adam let him
know you're part of the culture don't be
afraid pineapples in the chat for the
swingers pineapples in the chat for
everybody
here we are i'm so sorry august was
spicy okay i didn't know if it was me or
corey's gonna do another spin cause we
did get a great super chat come in
jordan thank you
brainstorm mystery shot hey
pickle one the pickle's gone pickle's
gone you've been going at two minutes
all right everyone avoiding the i don't
trust them
no trust it don't try i know better
not on this horny episode he's not
drinking random weights
it tastes healthy but like it's like a
mix of ginger and pickle which is an
oddly citrus turmeric
it is a turmeric adjacent i like it it's
very yellow
[Music]
who do you think this is guys in the
chat please let us know it's hard to get
the the dedication you can really see
the details
up there looks like a it almost looks
like a satanic pig
[Laughter]
my finest work
well if you want to submit your own
clips of the week of your own join our
discord uh you got to be 18 years older
but you can click the link in the
description below join the new rockstars
discord you can send a clip of the week
you can send in voicemails which we
promise we'll do on the show one of
these days uh make sure you check out
newrockstarsmerch.com
uh check out all our awesome merch
options there we hope you've had a great
week we've had a great friday uh we hope
john doesn't take away our wheel when he
comes back we'll have lots of fun stuff
on there thank you coy and eric for
being here today happy birthday
get up turn
away on my birthday
i almost killed him on his birthday what
irony that would have been
i looked around
oh my gosh i think we got the clip
that was terrifying have a great weekend
everybody enjoy it have a great labor
day weekend we will not be here on
monday but we will see you on tuesday
have a great time we bless you uh later
skaters goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you